democrats are ready to ship grandpa joe
off to the nursing home for good
more fallout from a new york times
report which indicates many in the party
are looking to dump joe biden in 2024
because of his advanced age and a series
of calamities under his watch but the
white house press secretary laughing off
any questions about biden's fitness for
office
does the president have the stamina
physically and mentally do you think to
continue on even after 2024. you're
asking me this question oh my gosh he's
the president of the united states you
know he i can't even keep up with it we
just got back from new mexico we just
got back from california that is not a
question that we should be even asking
just look at the work that he does
you know jesse she can't keep up with
the uh president jesse jr could keep up
with the president
don wasn't even smiling did you see that
seriously he got the memo a memo went
out probably a polling memo or some
power brokers at the democratic national
committee said this guy was good for
getting trump out of there but he's not
performing he says performance issues
you know what i'm talking about greg so
yes cnn is now
see it now cnn is now in on the get rid
of joe thing the times is in on it it's
it's out so
he's bad for ratings at cnn he's bad for
business look at the stock market you
think the donors want to suffer a
recession this summer i mean come on
we're wiping out everything that we've
gained under his presidency so far and
they've had it so they're going to put
him out to pasture right after the
shredding in the midterms and the
question is how long is it going to take
joe to understand that that's what's
happening because the man has pride he's
a biden he loves himself he's wanted to
be president his entire life he's run
three times so maybe susan rice she gets
in there you know the bombers are
circling someone has to tell joe axelrod
is sending smoke signals he's got to go
because the other people that are
running for president in 2024 they need
time to fundraise to contact donors this
thing's had been lickety-split after the
midterms yeah as dana predicted
as i did a long time ago the friday no
the wednesday before thanksgiving no the
monday after thanksgiving what a memory
you know the judge why don't they just
give him a gold watch
you know why because he's gotten a lot
of them from his son's traveling around
the world
okay only kidding this is good here's
some here's the problem
with when you listen to kareem
saint san pierre is that yeah okay the
the problem is she says oh my gosh she's
the president of the united states of
course she's up to it what does one have
to do with the other and then she says
she says that um
the the president is going to do what
the president is going to do who does
that remind you of kamala harris it's
like they're talking in verbal circles
but but in the end
this is about joe biden not wanting to
give up the spotlight he is so convinced
and so egotistical that he doesn't want
to give it up and maybe it might just be
about people saying joe we want you to
stay there because we don't want to give
it to kamala
okay that kamala is just so horrible
just stay in there we'll do what we got
to do you know we'll put you away but
the democrats can't be seen as pushing
kamala out of the way right off the bat
so i think kamala has a big piece of it
but i i really think karine saint pierre
i think her answer was ridiculous i
can't keep up with him he's going to do
what he's going to do and you know
that's not a question you should ask are
you kidding the man stumbles up air
force one every time he walks up i mean
he is embarrassing
you know i gotta say though dana i've
said this last week and i find myself
repeating myself again which is a
surprise uh
we're giving him kind of we're getting
him a get out of jail free pass on the
stuff that he actually does by just
talking about his cognitive impairment
yeah i i agree like i always say like no
the buck stops there these are his
decisions these are his policies and he
owns them so the media did something
that now you're going to see it forever
they broke the seal right now you're
going to see it everywhere because now
there's no putting this horse back in
the barn it is that how many metaphors
can i use uh in this uh you're attitude
um the other thing you're going to start
seeing is these democrats are distancing
themselves from biden or they're running
against their own party but look beneath
the surface for example the senator in
nevada who's on the run her name is uh
catherine
cortez masto
she's basically saying oh no like i'm
distancing myself from that but she
votes with joe biden 98 of the time and
you're going to see a lot of democrats
try to do this between now and then also
tomorrow morning at 9 00 a.m at the
white house all the house democrats are
going to the white house to have a
messaging meeting on the economy
that's not the meeting they need to have
the meeting they need to have is on the
economy on policy not just on messaging
last word geraldo what do you think
vulnerable malleable
over all those things uh but i thought
to the judge's point the new york post
had it so cleverly couched today
democrats can be forgiven for
considering the possibility of only
kamala harris standing between them and
a return of donald trump and saying 80
is the new 75.
80 is the new 75. no i think his problem
is you know he's an old 79. he's only
eight months older than i am
and he he lacks a certain vigor energy
and i think it's tragic i mean you can
argue with his policies of course i like
everyone else i've ridden this uh this
stock market uh very rocky i think i'd
be working until i'm a hundred at this
rate uh i i remember when the crash
happened in 2008 i was living in
edgewater right on the hudson river i
had a dock there with a pool on it and i
was swimming in the nude the moon was
out i got out i started yelling i'm not
selling i'm not selling anyway you had
to throw when you were nude i'm not
selling ah did you just had a boat on
the river
well up next the gun deal gets real in
congress but aoc says one aspect is
racist hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i
want you to do me a favor i want you to
click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not gonna miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now